in late 2018 tourists will be heading
into space and as a race on to get them
there I've done lot of adventurous
things on earth for going into spaces
kind of the ultimate adventure
Virgin Galactic would at last take
paying customers beyond the stratosphere
but their efforts might be eclipsed by
SpaceX a company planning to send two
tourists around the moon taking them
further into space than any human since
in 1972 science fiction is becoming
science fact the first that will happen
when you're in space is just a feeling
of weightlessness being free like a bird
no strings attached
watching the beautiful earth the blue
waters the landmasses the darkness of
the universe in the back I can't think
about a better place to be there's a new
breed of would-be astronauts for whom
the sky is no limit it's very difficult
to be an adventurer on earth today most
of the world has already discovered
observing on my part in traveling around
world but space that is where the true
frontier is for us in 2018 being
adventure that's what we gotta go but
it's not in everyone's reach multi
millionaire entrepreneur / Wimmer will
be one of the first tourists to go into
space with private company Virgin
Galactic going to space ain't cheap I've
certainly spent more than a million
dollars the ticket itself then you got
training and it starts to add up if all
goes to plan in 2018
Virgin Galactic will launch mr. Wimmer
to the edge of the atmosphere where
he'll be able to look back down on earth
but Elon Musk's aerospace company SpaceX
plans to go one step further on a flyby
loop around the moon its orders of
magnitude more difficult to get to orbit
or to go around them
the energy is the fuel the power the
materials are on a whole different level
we have a liftoff 32 minutes past the
hour liftoff on Apollo 11
only 24 astronauts have ever made the
almost 240,000 miles to earth clearest
neighbor in 2018 to paying customers
could be the first humans to venture
that far into space for over 40 years
but this mission is shrouded in mystery
they've not disclosed who's actually
going but but someone with the means of
paying for private rocket launch and a
trip that has never been done before
there are serious doubts whether these
ambitious targets can be reached in 2018
SpaceX has yet to carry out fundamental
tests on the launcher but if these
missions do go ahead they'll be
dangerous ventures only about 550 people
in total have ever been to space hands
launching and still a risky endeavor
[Music]
until we get that perfected it's going
to be one of the challenges private
space companies face obviously a major
malfunction 18 people have died in
spaceflight and one of Virgin Galactic's
own test pilots lost his life in
training in 2014
once you're in space everything from
orbital debris traveling at 17,500 miles
an hour to the loss of bone and muscle
density which could have detrimental
effects to your health you have got to
take risk you are pushing the boundaries
family friends they tend to be more
concerned I have signed a letter of
consent I take on the the risk but I'm
aware what I'm doing this boom in the
commercial space industry marks a new
era in space travel the fact that the
private sector has to compete with one
another requires they innovate and that
will help drive down cost rising access
to space as more and more people go to
space and we master space tourism
that's gonna enable
economy is in his face to be able to go
to the moon to asteroids to Mars
all because we lowered the cost of
access to space
I could see space travel being open to
the masses within a decade and openings
phase out to the masses may have an
impact on the way humans see the earth
itself when Apollo 8 came around the
dark side of the Moon and saw earth for
the first time as a whole disc that gave
us a sense of how small we are space
tourism has the ability to help change
humanity's perspective on what it means
to be human and what it means to take
care of the earth
[Music]
you